time now for morning rounds a look at
the medical news of the week as
firefighters in California get closer to
fully containing the fires people in the
region have had to deal with massive
amounts of smoke in the air due to
weathering patterns earlier in the week
some of the wildfire smoke from
California actually drifted as far as
New York thick smog could be seen
throughout parts of California forcing
many residents to wear masks when they
were outside according to the air
quality index some areas are still
experiencing moderate amounts of
pollutants although air quality has
improved over the past few days here to
discuss this and more as CBS News
medical contributor dr. David agus good
morning to you morning so there was a
pulmonologist who was quoted in the New
York Times who said if this kind of air
quality from wildfires doesn't get
people concerned I don't know what will
what are the health concerns surrounding
the wildfires you know when you burn
something there's particulate matter
that goes in the air and it gets stuck
in the lung and then your body tries to
get rid of it and it makes this immune
response you get lots of inflammation in
the lung and this can stay there for
long periods of time you know I was
evacuated for my home our kids you know
they canceled school in California they
canceled the Stanford Berkeley football
game of all things because they'd want
people out there you couldn't see in
front of you it was wild you see people
wearing these masks one do those help at
any point and and really what are the
strategies to avoid getting sick
so there are mess that help they call in
95 or n 100 and that's the size of the
poor can actually block the particular
matter
the problem is it makes it harder to
breathe and so you have to breathe
through that filter and so people with
cardiac problems that makes your heart
rate faster and so masks help no
question about it but the kids stay
indoors the kids turn off your you know
air conditioning that brings in air from
the outside the kids don't do strenuous
exercise well you have to breathe deeper
when there's a particular matter in the
air how significant an uptick in
hospital visits have there been and and
are we still learning about the
long-term health effects of this kind of
thing no question I mean you look at
Beijing you look at you know parts of
India where they have this on a daily
basis and what we're seeing is dramatic
up takes in the rates of cancer and
heart disease we're having an increase
in hospitalization visits here both
during the up
and for weeks two months afterwards
because of the response and so this is
real and this is going to be something
that is more and more common we have to
figure out better ways of filtering the
air in the house and dealing with it as
individuals we're gonna have to learn to
live with this you know long-term
effects that we'll see from it as well
up next peanuts the most common food
allergen among children in the US and
it's also a problem for many adults for
those with a severe allergy peanuts can
be deadly right now there are no
approved treatment options one study
shows what could be on the horizon
published in the New England Journal of
Medicine study looked at a phase three
trial of a drug called AR 101 496 out of
the 551 participants for ages four to 17
the trial tested how much peanut protein
they could ingest after taking the drug
and what can we say about this is this a
big deal I love the fact that it's
called AR 101 all it is is ground up
peanuts where they take out the fat when
you call AR one but it really is a
remarkable study because what they did
was they took kids and these are kids
one in 50 kids in the United States has
a peanut allergy and they are scared to
death you know boys are afraid to kiss a
girl cuz she a have peanuts you know
they can get an anaphylactic reaction
and potentially die sitting in a chair
with someone just that peanuts can be
you know deadly to them and they gave
them the small amounts of peanuts that
went up day by day and they actually
tolera is a turned off the immune
response against the peanuts and so for
the rest of their life they'll have one
of these capsules or many of the kids
afterwards actually switch to having two
peanut M&Ms every day and that same
amount every day basically turns off the
immune response not so they can go and
have peanut brittle but so that they're
not afraid and they don't lie in fear
every time they go out with friends and
they don't have to wipe off every
surface when they sit down it really
changes their life two-thirds in this
study these kids got better by the way
in the study the adults didn't benefit
from it it was just the kids earlier
with it and then we're done yeah what
about side effects from the drug and
then I guess how what was the inherent
risk even with eating peanut products
after that there's no question there
were side effects to this and that some
of the kids had a real reaction to it
and didn't do
well with the study but many of the kids
did better there were side effects the
placebo but much less obviously and then
for the rest of their life they're not
cured but they figure out a way to live
in less fear and I think that's critical
and hopefully this will be on the market
and fda-approved sometime next year
really change the lives of a lot of
children in this country you know rather
than later from your lips to bad beer
Thank You dr. David agus appreciate you
oh my pleasure